Bem-vindo de volta a entendendo informação e computação quântica. Meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação da IBM
Quantum. Esta é a 16ª e última aula da série e o tema da aula é computação quântica tolerante a falhas.
Ao longo das três aulas anteriores, vimos vários exemplos de códigos de correção de erros quânticos que podem detectar e nos permitir
corrigir erros quânticos, desde que não ocorram erros em excesso. Se quisermos usar a correção de erros para computação quântica, porém, ainda há muitos
problemas que precisam ser tratados, incluindo a realidade de que nossos gates quânticos, medições e preparações de estado
provavelmente serão imperfeitos. Portanto, por exemplo, se vamos realizar a correção de erros em um
ou mais qubits que foram codificados usando um código de correção de erros quânticos, teremos que fazer isso com gates e medições que por si mesmos
têm uma chance de não funcionar corretamente. E isso significa não apenas falhar em detectar ou corrigir erros, mas possivelmente
introduzir novos erros. Além disso, também precisamos realizar as computações de interesse usando novamente gates que não são
perfeitos. E certamente não podemos arriscar decodificar informação quântica com o intuito de realizar computações e depois
recodificar quando terminarmos, porque erros podem ocorrer quando a proteção de um código de correção de erros quânticos está ausente.
Isso significa que temos que descobrir como realizar gates quânticos diretamente em qubits lógicos que nunca ficam sem a
proteção de um código de correção de erros quânticos. Isso é uma exigência alta, mas é sabido que desde que o nível de ruído
fique abaixo de um certo valor limiar, é de fato possível realizar computações quânticas arbitrariamente grandes de forma confiável usando hardware ruidoso, pelo menos
em teoria. E discutiremos esse fato criticamente importante mais adiante na aula. Aqui está uma breve visão geral da
aula. Vamos começar com um modelo básico para computação quântica tolerante a falhas, incluindo uma breve discussão
de modelos de ruído junto com uma metodologia geral para implementar um circuit quântico de forma tolerante a falhas.
Depois passaremos para a questão da propagação de erros em circuits quânticos tolerantes a falhas e como
controlá-la. Em particular, discutirei implementações de gates transversais que oferecem uma forma muito simples de controlar a propagação de erros.
Embora haja uma limitação fundamental que nos impede de usar esse método
exclusivamente. Também falarei sobre uma metodologia diferente envolvendo os chamados magic states, que oferece um caminho diferente para controlar a propagação de erros
em circuits quânticos tolerantes a falhas. Embora não seja o único método conhecido e, finalmente, a aula
conclui com uma discussão bastante de alto nível do teorema do limiar, ao qual aludi há pouco.
Esse teorema afirma que circuits quânticos arbitrariamente grandes podem ser implementados de forma confiável desde que a taxa de erro de todos os componentes
envolvidos fique abaixo de um certo valor limiar finito. Em geral, esse valor limiar
depende do código de correção que usamos, bem como das escolhas específicas que fazemos para implementações tolerantes a falhas de
gates e medições quânticos, mas não do tamanho do circuit sendo implementado. E isso nos dá boas razões para acreditar que computações quânticas em larga escala
um dia se tornarão realidade. Vamos começar discutindo um modelo básico para computação quântica tolerante a falhas,
que é naturalmente baseado em circuits quânticos e códigos de correção de erros quânticos. Para fins dessa discussão,
vamos imaginar que temos um circuit quântico que esperamos implementar, como o mostrado aqui. Isso é um
circuit de teleporte incluindo a preparação do EBIT. Mas os detalhes não importam muito para essa discussão. E você pode imaginar que
esse é qualquer outro circuit quântico, possivelmente um circuit muito maior que inclui preparações de estado, operações unitárias
e medições. Esse circuit, claro, representa um ideal, e uma implementação real
dele não será perfeita. A questão natural a se fazer é o que poderia dar
errado? Bem, há bastante coisa que pode dar errado. Por exemplo, as inicializações de estado geralmente não serão
perfeitas. É claro que os gates unitários não serão perfeitos e tampouco as
medições. E além disso, os próprios qubits serão suscetíveis a ruídos, incluindo decoerência, em todo momento
da computação, mesmo quando nada está acontecendo com esses qubits e eles estão simplesmente armazenando informação quântica. Em outras palavras, praticamente
tudo pode dar errado. Há uma exceção, porém, ou pelo menos essa é uma suposição típica, e
é que qualquer computação clássica envolvida provavelmente não será defeituosa, porque para todos os efeitos práticos
as computações clássicas são basicamente perfeitas. Então, por exemplo, se rodarmos um algoritmo clássico de correspondência para
calcular correções para erros do surface code, realmente não precisamos nos preocupar que essa computação clássica possa ser defeituosa. Mas qualquer coisa que
envolva diretamente informação quântica pode ser. É claro que precisamos de um modelo preciso pelo qual possamos associar
probabilidades a várias coisas que possam dar errado. E se quiséssemos, poderíamos criar um modelo tão complicado quanto quisermos para refletir da melhor forma o que
realmente acontece na realidade. Se o modelo for complicado demais, porém, pode acabar sendo difícil ou impossível de trabalhar ou de
dizer algo interessante sobre ele. Um exemplo muito simples de modelo de ruído que as pessoas frequentemente consideram
é o modelo de ruído estocástico independente, onde erros ou falhas afetando diferentes componentes em diferentes
momentos — ou seja, em diferentes localizações no circuit — são independentes.
Por exemplo, poderíamos dizer que todo gate falha com uma certa probabilidade, que bit flips e phase flips acontecem com qubits armazenados com uma probabilidade diferente
por unidade de tempo e assim por diante. Mas a suposição é que não há correlação entre diferentes
erros. Agora, você pode se opor a esse modelo porque provavelmente haverá algumas correlações entre
erros. Por exemplo, provavelmente há uma pequena chance de um erro catastrófico que destrói todos os qubits de uma vez.
Ou talvez mais provavelmente, podem haver erros que são localizados mas que afetam múltiplos componentes.
E ninguém diz o contrário. Mas ainda assim, esse modelo representa uma base simples que em
essência representa a ideia de que a natureza é imprevisível, mas não é maliciosa e não está tentando intencionalmente
arruinar computações quânticas. Há outros modelos de ruído indiscutivelmente mais realistas que são frequentemente considerados. E independentemente do
modelo que escolhemos, se se descobrir que nosso modelo nos leva por um caminho errado e aprendemos algo novo sobre os erros em
qualquer sistema com que estejamos trabalhando, podemos naturalmente formular e considerar diferentes modelos de erro. A seguir, vamos dar
uma olhada em uma estratégia básica para implementar circuits quânticos de forma tolerante a falhas. Então vamos considerar um
circuit quântico lógico, ou seja, um circuit quântico ideal que estamos interessados em rodar. Por exemplo, poderíamos considerar o mesmo circuit de
antes, que agora está um pouco mais esticado porque vamos precisar de um pouco mais de espaço para a implementação tolerante a falhas dele. Primeiro
as preparações de estado, gates unitários e medições não serão realizados diretamente como gates únicos ou como
medições ou preparações de estado de um único qubit, mas sim serão realizados pelos chamados gadgets, que
podem envolver múltiplos qubits e múltiplas operações. Aqui nesse diagrama,
ilustrei isso desenhando caixas roxas ao redor dessas coisas. E você pode pensar nessas caixas roxas como sendo pequenos circuits ou operações que são
apenas rotulados pela preparação de estado ou gate que pretendemos implementar. Em segundo lugar, precisamos proteger
os qubits usando um código de correção de erros. Portanto, não serão os próprios qubits lógicos que conectam esses diferentes gadgets, mas sim os gadgets atuam sobre
os qubits físicos que codificam esses qubits lógicos. E vale a pena enfatizar aqui que os qubits lógicos que nos importam
nunca são expostos, o que significa que esses qubits lógicos passarão toda sua existência sendo protegidos por qualquer
código de correção de erros quânticos que estivermos usando. E finalmente, realizamos a correção de erros em nossos qubits codificados
repetidamente ao longo da computação, basicamente sempre que temos a chance. E é criticamente importante que façamos
isso. Intuitivamente falando, à medida que os erros ocorrem, aleatoriedade ou incerteza começa a se acumular no estado de nossos
qubits e precisamos trabalhar constantemente para remover essa aleatoriedade ou entropia. E isso acontece por meio da correção de erros.
Então você pode pensar nesses passos de correção de erros como pequenas geladeiras lógicas ou bombas de calor que
permitem que os qubits lógicos permaneçam frios para que a computação possa funcionar corretamente.
Uma vez que todas essas escolhas tenham sido feitas, ou seja, a seleção de todos os gadgets, bem como do código e assumindo um modelo de ruído particular, há uma
questão fundamental que podemos nos fazer, que é: isso está ajudando de verdade? Estamos melhorando as coisas ou
estamos piorando? Se houver muito ruído, podemos muito bem estar piorando as coisas,
assim como o código de Shor de 9 qubits piora as coisas se a chance de um erro for muito alta.
Mas se o ruído estiver abaixo de um certo limiar, então todo esse trabalho extra nos levará a algum lugar. E como discutiremos ao final da aula,
caminhos se abrem para uma redução adicional do erro. Nessa parte da aula, discutiremos a propagação de erros em circuits quânticos tolerantes a falhas
tendo a estrutura básica que acabei de descrever. Isso se revela uma preocupação
central porque se não conseguirmos controlar a propagação de erros, os erros vão rapidamente superar nossos esforços de correção de erros.
Mas se formos capazes de controlar a propagação de erros, então nosso código terá uma chance muito melhor
de se manter para que os erros possam ser corrigidos a uma taxa alta o suficiente para permitir que nossas computações
funcionem. O ponto de partida para essa discussão é a percepção de que gates de dois qubits, ou gates de múltiplos qubits mais
geralmente, podem propagar erros mesmo quando funcionam corretamente.
Por exemplo, considere um gate C-NOT. E suponha que um erro X ocorre no qubit de controle antes do gate C-NOT
ser realizado. Bem, um erro X funciona como um gate X. E descobrimos que
o circuit à esquerda é equivalente ao da direita, onde erros X ocorrem em ambos os qubits depois do C-NOT.
Essa é uma propagação de erros porque a infeliz localização do erro X à esquerda efetivamente o transforma em
dois erros X à direita. E nunca vamos escapar disso. Enquanto usarmos gates C-NOT, sempre haverá
uma chance de que um erro X ocorra no qubit de controle logo antes dele, que então se propaga para dois erros X
depois. Mas como veremos, desde que tomemos medidas para limitar o dano que isso causa, ficaremos bem. E aliás,
o mesmo fenômeno ocorre quando temos um erro Z no qubit alvo logo antes de um C-NOT. E discutimos isso
anteriormente e você pode verificar essas igualdades simplesmente realizando as multiplicações ou pode verificá-las usando
o Qiskit. O resultado é que isso causará em ambos os casos erros correlacionados em múltiplos qubits. E claro, não devemos
esquecer que os próprios gates C-NOT também podem ser defeituosos, o que também pode causar erros correlacionados.
Adicionando à nossa preocupação, gates subsequentes de dois qubits podem propagar esses erros ainda mais.
Por exemplo, se temos três gates C-NOT assim, assim como encontramos quando medimos geradores X do estabilizador, por exemplo, então um único erro pode
se propagar rapidamente para múltiplos qubits. E se isso acontecer dentro de um único bloco de código, por exemplo, significando um conjunto de
qubits que juntos codificam um qubit lógico, qualquer código de correção de erros que tenhamos escolhido não vai
ter chance nenhuma, porque os códigos são projetados para corrigir erros de baixo peso, não erros de alto peso como esse.
E então isso é algo que devemos ter sempre em mente enquanto pensamos sobre os gadgets e as
etapas de correção de erros em circuits quânticos tolerantes a falhas. A forma mais simples conhecida de mitigar a propagação de erros em circuits quânticos tolerantes a falhas
é implementar gates de forma transversal e vou explicar o que isso significa
em um momento. Então vamos manter a figura da nossa implementação tolerante a falhas na tela apenas como apoio visual.
A ideia aqui é que para alguns códigos de correção de erros quânticos, certos gates podem ser implementados de forma transversal, o que
significa implementá-los usando gadgets que são produtos tensoriais de operações onde cada operação atua apenas em um
único qubit dentro de cada bloco de código. Isso é mais fácil de explicar por meio de exemplos. O primeiro e
provavelmente o exemplo mais simples é a implementação transversal de gates de Pauli.
A ideia é que gostaríamos de construir gadgets para cada um dos gates em nosso circuit. E em todos os casos, esses gadgets
operam em blocos de código como vemos para os gates X e Z no final do nosso circuit de teleporte. Claro, não podemos
decodificar, aplicar um gate de Pauli e depois recodificar, porque isso deixaria um qubit lógico desprotegido e erros
podem se propagar dentro do bloco de código como resultado da recodificação.
Felizmente, não precisamos fazer isso desde que usemos um código estabilizador, porque todo código estabilizador permite que operações de Pauli
sejam aplicadas diretamente em nossos qubits lógicos. E de fato, podemos fazer isso com um produto tensorial de gates de Pauli
nos qubits físicos usados para a codificação.
Por exemplo, se considerarmos o surface code 3x3 que surgiu no final da aula anterior, então podemos implementar gates X e Z no qubit lógico
codificado por esse código fazendo o produto tensorial de gates X e Z junto com gates identidade nos padrões que são
sugeridos aqui. Essa é uma implementação transversal desses gates porque cada uma dessas operações de gate individuais
atua apenas em um único qubit dentro de cada bloco de código.
Estamos usando apenas gates de qubit único aqui, então é de certa forma trivial, mas em todo caso, gadgets como esse não causarão a propagação de erros.
Agora, qualquer um dos gates individuais em um gadget como esse pode falhar, e isso introduzirá
erros, mas sempre realizaremos a correção de erros imediatamente após cada gadget. E desde que a taxa de erro seja
baixa o suficiente, o código de correção de erros corrigirá esses erros.
E como eu disse, isso é sempre possível para gates de Pauli em todo código estabilizador.
Embora você tenha que identificar o padrão correto de gates de Pauli nos gadgets para implementar adequadamente qualquer operação lógica de Pauli que você
deseje. Para outro exemplo que envolve gates de dois qubits. Desta vez podemos considerar implementações transversais
de gates C-NOT. Em particular, para todo código CSS, sempre podemos implementar um gate C-NOT
entre dois qubits lógicos simplesmente realizando gates C-NOT em pares correspondentes de qubits físicos.
E isso satisfaz a condição de ser transversal porque cada um desses gates C-NOT individuais atua apenas
em um único qubit dentro de cada bloco de código. Por exemplo, o primeiro gate C-NOT atua apenas no qubit mais alto
dentro de cada bloco de código; o segundo gate C-NOT atua apenas no segundo qubit de cima e assim
por diante. Nesse caso, poderíamos ter uma propagação de erros porque gates C-NOT propagam erros e não há
como evitar isso. Mas o ponto-chave é que a propagação de erros nunca acontece dentro de um único bloco de código. Por exemplo,
um erro X poderia ocorrer no qubit mais alto do bloco de código superior logo antes do gadget ser realizado e o primeiro C-NOT
dentro do gadget propagará esse erro para o qubit mais alto no bloco inferior. Mas os dois erros resultantes estão
agora em blocos de código separados. Portanto, as etapas de correção de erros que ocorrem após o gadget serão capazes de corrigir esses erros individualmente, porque esses
erros afetam apenas um único qubit dentro de cada bloco de código.
Em contraste, se a propagação de erros acontecesse dentro do mesmo bloco de código, poderíamos estar com problemas, porque a
propagação de erros estaria transformando um erro de baixo peso em um erro de alto peso que nosso código pode não ser capaz de lidar.
Essa implementação não funciona para códigos não-CSS, mas desde que usemos um código CSS, sempre podemos implementar gates C-NOT
de forma transversal dessa maneira. E para mais um exemplo, todo
gate de Clifford pode ser implementado de forma transversal para o código de Steane. E de fato para qualquer color code, que é uma das coisas realmente boas sobre os color codes;
em particular, um gate Hadamard em um qubit lógico pode ser implementado realizando gates Hadamard individualmente em
cada um dos qubits físicos, e um gate S lógico pode ser implementado não por um gate S em cada qubit, mas sim por um
gate S† em cada qubit físico. Portanto, o resultado é que implementações transversais de gates são inerentemente
tolerantes a falhas, porque nunca propagam erros dentro de um único bloco de código, o que dá às etapas de correção de erros uma chance de corrigir
quaisquer erros introduzidos ou propagados pelos gates usados nesses gadgets. Isso é ótimo e é uma forma
muito simples de construir gadgets tolerantes a falhas, e há diferentes códigos que permitem implementações transversais de diferentes gates
como gates T; mas infelizmente é impossível para qualquer código não-trivial implementar um
conjunto universal de gates de forma transversal, o que é um fato conhecido como o teorema de Eastin-Knill; em termos mais técnicos, o que ele
diz é que desde que nosso código tenha distância de pelo menos dois, o conjunto de gates que podem ser implementados de forma transversal necessariamente gera um
conjunto discreto de operações a menos de uma fase global, e portanto esse conjunto não é universal porque conjuntos universais de gates
necessariamente geram infinitas operações. Não vou explicar a prova desse teorema, que faz uso de alguns
fatos básicos sobre grupos e álgebras de Lie, que não são pré-requisitos para esta série. Mas a ideia básica é
que famílias infinitas de operações transversais não podem nos manter dentro do espaço do código porque diferenças minúsculas
em operações transversais são bem aproximadas por operações de Pauli de baixo peso, que o código detecta como
erros. Portanto, ficamos muito satisfeitos quando podemos implementar gates de forma transversal. Mas para qualquer código que escolhamos, sabemos que sempre
haverá alguns gates que não podemos implementar dessa forma. E então precisamos buscar gadgets alternativos. Pelo
teorema de Eastin-Knill, sabemos que não é possível implementar um conjunto universal de gates quânticos de forma transversal, nem mesmo
para um código de correção de erros quânticos de distância 2. Portanto, precisamos encontrar outras formas de implementar gates de forma tolerante a falhas
pelo menos para alguns gates. Uma forma bem conhecida de fazer isso é por meio do uso dos chamados magic states.
Para fins dessa discussão, vamos lembrar os gates S e T, que são
gates de qubit único definidos conforme mostrado aqui na tela. Vamos também observar que, primeiro, S é uma operação de Clifford,
o que decorre da nossa definição de operações de Clifford. Mas você também pode verificar que conjugar uma matriz de Pauli por S sempre nos dá mais ou menos outra
matriz de Pauli. E segundo, T não é uma operação de Clifford. E de fato, se combinarmos T com Hadamard e C-NOT, ambos
dos quais são operações de Clifford, obtemos um conjunto universal de gates quânticos. Portanto, não podemos implementar um gate T
usando apenas operações de Clifford e medições na base padrão. Mas podemos de fato implementar um gate T usando
operações de Clifford e medições na base padrão se, além disso, tivermos uma cópia do estado mostrado aqui
na tela, que é o gate T aplicado a um estado plus.
Esse estado é chamado de magic state, embora não seja único nesse aspecto.
O termo magic state também é usado para se referir a diferentes estados que desempenham um papel similar a esse em variações de todo esse
esquema. Por exemplo, o circuit mostrado aqui faz o trabalho. E não é muito difícil verificar
isso. Aqui está o estado inicial com o sistema superior à direita. E se aplicarmos o gate C-NOT e simplificarmos, obtemos o
estado mostrado aqui.
Portanto, se medirmos o qubit inferior e obtivermos zero, o que acontece com probabilidade 1/2, não realizamos o
gate S e a saída é T aplicado a s.
E se medirmos um, o que também acontece com probabilidade 1/2 claro, aplicamos o gate S e o resultado líquido é
que a saída é novamente T aplicado a s. Essa não é a única forma de fazer isso, aliás. Há outros circuits de aparência similar
que realizam a mesma tarefa, mas é uma forma de fazê-lo.
Esse é um exemplo um tanto simplificado de algo conhecido como teleporte de gate quântico, ao qual aludi na aula 4, onde o teleporte é usado
não para enviar qubits, mas para aplicar gates. A conexão com o teleporte pode não estar totalmente clara aqui porque, como eu
disse, essa é uma versão simplificada, o que podemos nos permitir porque T é diagonal. Mas se você estiver interessado em
saber mais, as palavras-chave são teleporte de gate quântico.
E poderíamos também fazer algo similar para implementar um gate S, onde desta vez os únicos gates que precisamos são um gate C-NOT e um gate Z junto com a medição,
o que é útil se não tivermos uma implementação transversal de um gate S. Portanto, isso é interessante, mas não está
totalmente claro que isso realmente ajuda. No caso da implementação do gate T, por exemplo, estamos
conseguindo aplicar um gate T a um estado de entrada. Mas para fazer isso, parece que estamos aplicando um gate T a um estado plus para obter um
magic state. E a situação é similar para a implementação do gate S. O ponto é que não
precisamos necessariamente primeiro criar um estado plus e depois aplicar um gate T para obter um magic state. Há outras formas possíveis de obter esse estado. E em
particular, podemos fazer isso sem ter que nos preocupar com a propagação de erros em qualquer computação em que estejamos trabalhando, porque os magic states podem ser criados
separadamente. Isso permite uma implementação tolerante a falhas de um gate T, como descreverei brevemente agora.
Primeiro, não vamos realmente rodar o circuit simples de dois qubits mostrado aqui, mas em vez disso rodaremos esse circuit usando
qubits codificados em qualquer código de correção de erros que estivermos usando para nossa implementação tolerante a falhas. O que significa que os
gates unitários e as medições são realizados por gadgets tolerantes a falhas. E isso significa que também precisamos dos nossos
magic states codificados. Portanto, tudo será tolerante a falhas desde que consigamos os magic states codificados.
Estamos assumindo aqui, aliás, que já temos um gadget tolerante a falhas para um gate S. Se
estivéssemos usando o código de Steane, por exemplo, poderíamos simplesmente implementar o gate S de forma transversal. E para códigos para os quais isso não funciona, uma opção é
primeiro usar todo esse esquema para implementar um gate S de forma tolerante a falhas e depois usar essa implementação aqui.
Embora não seja a única opção. Mas de qualquer forma, voltando à implementação, a questão importante que resta é: como obtemos os nossos
magic states codificados, dado que ainda não temos uma implementação tolerante a falhas de um gate T para tornar isso
simples? E a ideia-chave é que podemos usar um processo probabilístico para criar magic states codificados. E se não
der certo, tudo bem. Podemos simplesmente descartar quaisquer tentativas malsucedidas e tentar de novo.
E isso não perturba a computação que realmente estamos tentando realizar, porque a criação de magic states é feita
separadamente. Uma forma típica de isso ser feito é por meio de um processo conhecido como destilação de magic states. E funciona da seguinte
forma. Temos um certo circuit conhecido como destilador. Fornecemos a esse destilador uma coleção de magic states ruidosos
e depois medimos todos os resultados, exceto um. E se condicionarmos todos os resultados de medição sendo zero,
então o que acontece é que o que sai é um magic state menos ruidoso, que pode então ser um dos qubits de entrada em
outro destilador. E o processo continua até que falharmos — porque um dos resultados de medição é não-zero e tentamos novamente — ou tenhamos um magic state
de qualidade suficientemente alta que possamos usá-lo com segurança para implementar um gate T na computação que nos interessa.
Há diferentes formas conhecidas de construir um destilador assim, mas todas funcionam basicamente da mesma forma, que é que são decodificadores para códigos estabilizadores,
o que significa que são os inversos de circuits de codificação, o que é bom porque significa que o destilador pode ser uma operação de Clifford.
E finalmente, esse processo de destilação na verdade ocorre no nível do qubit lógico. Portanto, na realidade,
tudo é feito usando gadgets para o destilador e as medições. Esse processo precisa
começar em algum ponto. Mas desde que a taxa de ruído não seja muito alta, é possível criar magic states ruidosos, mas bons o suficiente
para iniciá-lo. Por exemplo, aplicando um gate T ruidoso de verdade a um qubit em um estado plus e depois
codificando esse qubit. Então essa foi uma descrição de alto nível, mas espero ter dado uma ideia geral de como isso funciona.
É bem mais complicado do que implementar gates de forma transversal, mas ainda assim oferece uma forma de implementar um conjunto universal de gates quânticos
de forma tolerante a falhas, enquanto implementações transversais de gates sozinhas não conseguem fazer isso. Às vezes é afirmado
que o overhead para usar magic states para implementar gates de forma tolerante a falhas seguindo essas linhas seria muito alto,
onde a grande maioria do trabalho vai para destilar magic states e rodar a computação real é mais uma
consideração secundária. Mas isso na verdade não é tão claro e houve análises detalhadas que revelam que esse método
poderia ser de fato prático. Há vários outros esquemas conhecidos para implementar gates de forma tolerante a falhas. Deformação de código e troca de código são nomes
associados a alguns desses esquemas e novas formas continuam sendo desenvolvidas e refinadas, mas não descreverei esses
métodos nesta aula. Há outro problema importante relacionado às implementações tolerantes a falhas de circuits quânticos e
ele diz respeito às próprias etapas de correção de erros. Portanto, não se trata de implementar gates. Trata-se de realizar a
correção de erros de verdade. O problema é que se pensarmos nos circuits simples que
vimos pela primeira vez na aula 14 para medir geradores do estabilizador com base na estimativa de fase, descobrimos que eles não são
eles próprios tolerantes a falhas, porque poderiam potencialmente causar a propagação de erros dentro de um único bloco de código.
Isso remete à ideia de que qualquer coisa que envolva informação quântica é suscetível a erros, e isso inclui os próprios circuits que se destinam
a corrigir erros. Isso parece bastante problemático, mas há de fato múltiplas soluções conhecidas para esse problema. Mencionarei apenas algumas delas,
embora não vá explicar nenhuma delas em detalhes. E aliás, se você está tendo a ideia de que a computação quântica tolerante a falhas é
complicada e há muitos detalhes com os quais se preocupar, então isso é certamente compreensível porque é verdade. Há muitas peças em movimento
aqui e minha intenção com esta aula não é explicar todos os detalhes, mas sim dar apenas uma introdução básica de como tudo
funciona. Um método para correção de erros quânticos tolerante a falhas é conhecido como correção de erros de Shor, nomeado em homenagem a Peter
Shor, que propôs esse método pela primeira vez. A ideia é realizar cada medição de síndrome usando um chamado cat state,
que é a mesma coisa que um estado GHZ quando temos três qubits, mas pode ser generalizado para qualquer número de qubits que corresponda ao peso do gerador do estabilizador
que pretendemos medir. Em particular, o circuit mostrado aqui funciona para medir um gerador do estabilizador. E pode ser
mostrado que esse método não faz com que erros se propaguem dentro de um bloco de código.
Isso requer criar o próprio cat state. E para fazê-lo funcionar de forma confiável na presença de erros e gates potencialmente defeituosos, o método na verdade
exige que rodemos repetidamente circuits como esse e façamos inferências sobre onde diferentes erros podem ter ocorrido durante o
processo. Um método alternativo é conhecido como correção de erros de Steane, proposto pela primeira vez por Andrew Steane, e
esse método funciona de forma diferente e só funciona para códigos CSS. Nesse método, não realizamos as medições de síndrome nos estados quânticos codificados
no circuit que estamos tentando rodar, mas em vez disso propagamos intencionalmente os erros para um sistema de espaço de trabalho
e depois medimos esse sistema e detectamos os erros de forma clássica. Esta figura mostrada aqui mostra como fazer isso para erros X, caso em que os qubits de espaço de trabalho
são inicialmente configurados como uma codificação de um estado plus. Portanto, isso é basicamente uma
implementação transversal de um gate C-NOT que não deveria fazer nada porque o alvo está em um estado plus. Mas se houver
erros X nos qubits superiores, eles se propagarão para o sistema inferior e serão detectados. Há também um método similar para detectar erros Z
que não é mostrado aqui. Há também um método relacionado conhecido como correção de erros de Knill, proposto pela primeira vez por Manny Knill,
e é baseado no teleporte em vez de um C-NOT transversal, e isso permite que funcione para códigos estabilizadores arbitrários
e não apenas para códigos CSS.
A última coisa que discutirei nesta aula é um teorema muito importante conhecido como o teorema do limiar. Aqui está uma declaração um tanto informal
do teorema. Ele afirma que se tivermos qualquer circuit quântico com n gates, onde n pode ser tão grande quanto quisermos, então é
possível implementar esse circuit com alta precisão usando um circuit quântico ruidoso, desde que o nível de ruído
esteja abaixo de um certo valor limiar que é independente de n. E além disso, não é muito caro fazer isso no
sentido de que o tamanho do circuit ruidoso necessário é da ordem de n vezes uma certa potência constante do logaritmo de
n. Para enunciar o teorema de forma mais formal é necessário ser específico sobre o modelo de ruído, o que não farei nesta aula.
Pode ser provado, por exemplo, para o modelo de ruído estocástico independente que mencionei anteriormente, onde erros ocorrem
independentemente em cada possível localização no circuit com alguma probabilidade estritamente menor que esse valor limiar. Mas também pode ser
provado para modelos de ruído mais gerais onde pode haver correlações entre erros. Agora, este é um resultado teórico
e a forma típica de prová-lo não necessariamente se traduz em algo que faríamos de fato na prática, mas é ainda assim um
teorema muito importante em termos práticos. E a razão disso é que ele basicamente diz que não há barreira fundamental para realizar
computações quânticas usando componentes ruidosos.
Desde que a taxa de erro para esses componentes esteja abaixo desse valor limiar, eles podem ser usados para construir circuits quânticos confiáveis de tamanho arbitrário.
Outra forma de dizer é que se o teorema não fosse verdadeiro, seria difícil imaginar que a computação quântica em larga escala
um dia se tornasse realidade. Há muitos detalhes técnicos envolvidos em provas formais desse teorema, que não tentarei
comunicar. Mas vou tentar explicar a ideia básica em alto nível. E também tentarei conectar vagamente a ideia básica
ao que poderíamos esperar que acontecesse na prática. Então vamos supor que esse é nosso circuit. É o mesmo circuit que
temos discutido ao longo de toda a aula. Mas novamente, podemos imaginar que nosso circuit seja significativamente maior e mais complicado do que esse. Gostaríamos de
implementar esse circuit, mas todos os nossos componentes são ruidosos. E supondo que usemos o modelo de ruído estocástico independente
apenas por simplicidade, há alguma probabilidade P com a qual os erros ocorrem independentemente em cada possível localização.
Se o circuit fosse significativamente maior que o recíproco dessa probabilidade P, poderíamos ter bastante certeza de que uma
implementação direta dele não funcionaria corretamente. Portanto, passamos por todo o trabalho de implementar o circuit
de forma tolerante a falhas como discuti até agora nesta aula e nos fazemos a pergunta que levantei anteriormente, que é: estamos melhorando
as coisas ou estamos piorando? Bem, se a probabilidade P que representa a probabilidade de erro para cada um de nossos componentes for muito grande, então
isso não vai ajudar, assim como o código de Shor de 9 qubits não ajuda se a probabilidade de erro estiver acima de cerca de 3 e 3/4%.
Em particular, tornamos o circuit maior. Portanto, há muito mais localizações onde os erros podem ocorrer.
Porém, se P for pequeno o suficiente, isso vai ajudar. E o que efetivamente faremos é reduzir a probabilidade de erro
para a computação lógica que estamos realizando. Então vamos pensar sobre isso com
um pouco mais de detalhe. E para ver as ideias principais da forma mais simples possível, vamos supor que usamos o código de Steane de 7 qubits para correção de
erros, que permite a correção de até um erro por bloco de código. Portanto, para que um erro lógico
ocorra no circuit original, teremos que ter pelo menos dois erros caindo no mesmo bloco de código para nossa implementação tolerante a falhas.
Tendo em mente que há muitas formas diferentes de ter dois ou mais erros no mesmo bloco de código, pode-se argumentar que a probabilidade de um erro lógico
em cada localização no circuit original é no máximo C * P², onde C é um número que depende do código e dos
gadgets que usamos. Mas criticamente, não depende do tamanho do circuit original.
Portanto, se P for menor que o recíproco de C, que é o número que podemos tomar como nosso valor limiar, então isso
se traduz em uma redução de erro. Portanto, nosso trabalho duro em implementar o circuit de forma tolerante a falhas está dando resultado.
Porém, essa nova taxa de erro ainda pode ser muito alta para o circuit inteiro funcionar corretamente. Portanto, precisamos fazer
mais. Na prática, uma coisa natural a fazer nesse ponto é escolher um código melhor e gadgets melhores para reduzir a taxa de erro
a um ponto onde a implementação provavelmente funcionará.
Teoricamente, uma forma simples de argumentar que isso é possível é concatenar. Em outras palavras, pensamos
na implementação tolerante a falhas do circuit original como um novo circuit lógico. E depois o implementamos de forma tolerante a
falhas. E depois fazemos isso novamente e novamente quantas vezes precisarmos. E acontece que isso reduz o erro
muito rapidamente. E é assim que o teorema do limiar é tipicamente provado no papel.
Vou dar apenas uma ideia muito aproximada de como a taxa de erro diminui, deixando de fora os muitos detalhes técnicos necessários para
provar isso formalmente. Começamos com a probabilidade de erro P para nossos componentes originais. E se implementarmos o
circuit de forma tolerante a falhas, o erro diminui por um fator de C * P. Se depois tratarmos nossa implementação tolerante a falhas
como um circuit lógico e a implementarmos de forma tolerante a falhas, obtemos uma diminuição similar na taxa de erro. Mas
se pensarmos na taxa de erro efetiva para o circuit original, descobrimos que ela cai ainda mais, porque agora
estamos substituindo a taxa de erro P por C * P² porque essa é a taxa de erro efetiva após a implementação tolerante a falhas do primeiro nível.
Especificamente, após um pouco de álgebra, descobrimos que o erro cai para (CP)³ * P. E se
fizermos isso de novo, agora temos uma taxa de erro de (CP)^7 * P. E se
continuarmos fazendo isso por um total de K níveis, o que descobrimos é que o erro encolhe duplamente de forma exponencial em K. Portanto,
não precisamos fazer isso muitas vezes para tornar a taxa de erro extremamente pequena.
Enquanto isso, os circuits estão crescendo em tamanho, mas o tamanho só cresce de forma simplesmente exponencial em K, porque a cada
nível de tolerância a falhas, o tamanho de nosso circuit cresce por no máximo um fator determinado pelo tamanho máximo de
nossos gadgets. E quando tudo é reunido e uma escolha adequada para o número
de níveis de concatenação é feita, obtemos o teorema do limiar. Mas como já sugeri, há muitos detalhes necessários para tornar isso formal. Então,
qual é esse valor limiar na realidade? Bem, depende do código e dos gadgets que
usamos; para o código de Steane junto com a destilação de magic states, é minúsculo e provavelmente improvável de ser alcançado na
prática. Mas usando surface codes e gadgets de ponta, estima-se que seja em torno de 1%. O que não é
ruim. E à medida que novos códigos e métodos são descobertos, podemos razoavelmente esperar que aumente, enquanto simultaneamente o
nível de ruído nos componentes que construímos diminuirá. Chegar ao ponto em que
computações quânticas em larga escala possam ser implementadas de forma tolerante a falhas não será fácil e não acontecerá da noite para o dia.
Mas esse teorema, junto com os avanços em códigos quânticos e em hardware quântico que testemunhamos até hoje,
nos fornece o otimismo de que precisamos para continuar avançando em direção a esse objetivo final de construir um
computador quântico tolerante a falhas em larga escala. E esse é o final da aula e o final da série.
Espero sinceramente que você tenha encontrado valor na série e, se sim, por favor considere recomendá-la a um colega ou amigo.
Além disso, não deixe de conferir o IBM Quantum Learning para cursos e tutoriais adicionais, e se inscreva no canal do Qiskit
no YouTube, se ainda não fez isso, para ficar por dentro dos nossos futuros lançamentos de conteúdo. Obrigado por
assistir.